[Musique]
mariama pas ou si julie si si il me
semble entendre un son étrange
oui mais plutôt une musique une musique
joly qui viendraient de la ba ouai parla
du crois oui mais alors ça viendrait des
petits bois oui les petits bois
[Musique]
bonjour mes bons amis dont j'ai aussi dû
ce n'est un bon bah vous à mai 2009
quelles banques vont elles pas répondu à
ma chère amie kate honneur de musique
c'est à lui jamais là vous l'avez
entendu cette musique / j'ai entendu
j'ai entendu d'abord j'ai écouté ensuite
c'est joli n'est ce pas ou direct et les
feuilles chou oui j'en apprécie à celle
des harmonies bien que cette musique me
paraissent un peu rustre avec quelques
faiblesses dans le phrasé musical trop
il est certain monsieur du snap que vous
avez une véritable opinion de
spécialistes mais moi je laime tout
simplement cette musique parce que je la
trouvais nous montrent aussi tiens je
les regarde voilà casimir qui revient de
sa cueillette de fraises des bois
regarde récit lui qui joue ce pas
pousser vers sera mis un gros ballots
trop faible par jouer aussi bien
attention mais ses 19 passes en 10 duels
de casimir et puis un grand ballon trop
gonflé ça n'a rien de l'oeil regardez
les miens voyons mais mes chers amis
vous mais froide et parce que c'est une
boutade je les aime bien les miens pour
le sauver mais c'est très gentil ce que
vous dites là monsieur douces notes
parce que moi aussi je vous aime bien
mais c'est tout à fait naturel casimir
et je ne comprends pas pourquoi certains
s'évertuent à dire que nous entendons
pas encore mais moi non plus c'est tout
azimut que tu joue très bien et que tu
nous a rappelé ce qu'il faudrait faire
c'est que chacun nous faisons fabriquer
des mirlitons aux enfants mais nous
pourrions jouer ensemble ce serait
beaucoup plus joli que cela c'est très
facile j'ai apporté des des bambous pour
tout le monde et c'est une très belle
idée ça j'appelle les gens chantent les
enfants venez avec nous venez voir ça va
être formulée il avait tout ça veuille
égaliser tenez je vous ai apporté des
bambous
amis vous allez voir en 2008 on a
plusieurs tonalités vous allez voir
l'instrument qui va révolutionner la
musique
allez-y vous voulez monsieur du snam
mais un simple mirliton aussi bien fait
la faire vous savez comment on fabrique
des mirlitons les enfants oui oui et
bien pour ceux qui ne savent pas je vous
explique t on prend une tige de bambou à
une extrémité on est un morceau de
papier cigarette qu'on fixe avec un
élastique et ont fait une encoche et
dans sept ans de koch
on souffle pour faire la musique se
tendance à regarder c'est facile ça
[Musique]
m
bon puisque tout le monde est prêt on va
y aller nous savons tous par françois
mais j'ai l'impression de socios du club
a encore quelques petites mises au point
à faire
bon alors pour fait vous monsieur du
snob on attend qu au bout vos kazemi
robot ne paraît convenir il est tout
aussi facilement qu'on bricole vos
petites choses
jeune artiste matin à bricoler au nombre
exagéré pas nous faisons ça pour nous
amuser sans plus ne vous fâchez pas et
puis monsieur des snobs je suis sûr
qu'un artiste de votre talent peut très
bien prendre la chanson milieu n'est ce
pas monsieur desmond sans aucun doute
mon cher françois doute moins tartempion
on commence à vous n'êtes pas tout seul
d'accord alors je compte 1 2 3 4
on y va
les ppp
il
ils étaient tous
m
alors qu'en pensez vous c'était
formidable voilà vous le casimir tient
inventé un divertissement extraordinaire
oui on peut être commencé avec monsieur
du snob cette fois n'est ce pas monsieur
non c'est impossible impossible
impossible qu est ce qu est un truc qui
vous maudissent port bou et rodez au
papier trop fun plus élastique qui peut
être les unes après les autres
pensez vous qu on craque et qu'est ce
qui se passe justement je te sais déjà
ce qui est rond vert ou le bambou qui
trop élastique un veau la grosse
baudruche orange ça s'est fait comme ça
un voyou casimir soient gentils ne joue
pas avec les nerfs de ce pauvre monsieur
du snob et bien tant pis nous allons
continuer sur le sultan militants ne
m'étais dit cela tant pis enfin quel
dommage un artiste au talent toutes
catégories comme ça on pourra les tant
pis
[Musique]
m
je suis
ep
oui
m
[Musique]
et
oui